hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to let's
talk about Waterworld you know that's
almost the reaction I get I mean this
film is known as one of the great
all-time bombs it was the most expensive
movie made at the time and it didn't
even come close to making its money back
but is it really as bad as everybody
makes it sound does it deserve all the
bad press it continues to get even to
this day what's in this movie that just
pisses people off so much aside from the
obvious number one well there's
dangerous waters up ahead let's see if
we can get through this is Waterworld so
after we get the traditional Universal
we'll go with Earth's still having no
visible clouds we take a quick glimpse
into the future the future the polar ice
caps have melted covering the earth with
water those who survived have adapted
it's a trailer for another Al Gore movie
An Inconvenient Truth to somebody listen
to me so we see that mankind has adapted
into the Kevin Costner of blandness
Kevin Costner we see him take a piss put
it through a machine and proceed to
drink it there's a fitting metaphor for
this movie in here but I can't quite
figure it out
and just to give you an idea how boring
Costner's acting is just look at this
see he's actually in these shots he
hasn't left the frame he just leaves
such a small impact on the audience that
you can't even see him
that takes Talent he then comes across a
drifter and make some chitchat
well I owe you then no thanks I got all
the supplies I need two drifters meet
something needs to be exchanged I know
the cog nothing's free in Waterworld hey
it's the model the producers of this
movie always said but it turns out the
drifter stole his plant and an evil band
of water terrorist called the smokers
are up together and now we see exactly
what takes up the majority of time in
this stop Jeff just stuff oh look at
that stuff go have you ever seen so much
stuff happening at the same time oh now
he's finding some stuff that stuff must
be important because that stuff a lesson
to do this stuff oh look after that
stuff not that stuff over so you can
pick up that other stuff while you're
busy trying to handle this stuff
so he knocks out the other drifters boat
and the smokers catch up with the
drifter and shoot it which begs the
question why didn't they just shoot
Costner but let's leave the small flat
holes for the bigger plot holes he
reaches a city that sort of looks like a
paper mache toilet seat and sells a jar
of dirt for a ton of money he comes
across Hulk Hogan's barber here as he's
told about a map to dry land that
apparently is tattooed on the back of
the little girl one more make it two
I'm this rich look like a pile of water
I'm sure
that's an interesting pair of boots I'm
confused is he trying to establish
himself as the arch-nemesis are trying
to ask Costner out on a date before
Costner heads up though he's offered an
asian chick that's nice we can look to
her own for impregnation but too much of
that sort of thing it's undesirable
she's pregnant
you're going your way with all the
supplies you need you don't have
anything good time that was a good read
Costner but uh why don't you try it once
more and this time fucking care he's a
smoker spy maybe he's gay did they not
survive hot water so upon closer
inspection they find out that Costner is
a mutant Geils
what are mutants in this world you've
never given a full explanation but
apparently they're half-human half-fish
people they hold over time and everybody
hates them um why I mean I know
prejudice is a staple of mankind but you
have an apocalyptic world underwater and
a guy who can breathe underwater
Tim you shouldn't be putting them in a
net used to be tritium like royalty he
can solve like a bajillion problems in
this world and you're treating it like a
criminal
what's wrong with these people seriously
what's what the hey that gives me the
mucus out there with incredible powers
okay okay yeah so because the really
cool guy that can breathe underwater and
has a lot of helpful elements to him has
gills I guess he must be destroyed
therefore in the interest of Public
Safety
yes hereby sentence to be recycled into
what Keanu Reeves but suddenly the
smokers attack to take over the city led
by an evil man named Deacon played by
Dennis Hopper monkey actually something
I never quite got is how come there Cole
smokers I mean okay I can see that
everybody smokes but why does that make
them a terrorist group is there another
evil organization out there called the
vegetarians the shopaholics or how about
the deadliest forces of them all but
Ricky Perry Costner I want you to watch
very closely what these people are doing
this is called giving a shit you should
try it sometime it may be your acting
will improve okay now this is turning
into a water show just let the Universal
Studios Florida logo at the bottom and
the advertising takes care of itself
so no man named Gregor accidentally
pushes the lever that launches his hot
air balloon that he had in his room this
forces him to leave his friend Helen and
the little girl named Enola behind
so Helen ne NOLA have no choice but to
free Costner and have him lead them out
of the city
don't burn fun
this of course leads to you guessed it
Lars stop oh look he's pulling that
stuff if you start cutting that stuff
that will not you to start swinging up
this stuff
Chris messed up pull that stuff look out
for that stuff oh I'm out of material
little girl you take over
lady you're on is bow what's he gonna do
surrender no you can't what you gonna do
about so he tricks one of the boats into
firing at Dennis Hopper which results in
him losing an eye but our heroes get
away on Costner's boat as he shows his
appreciation to Helen for saving his
life
kid we've got a pitch over the side what
is better one day it dies now slow hero
everybody when he's not busy killing
kids he spends his time stealing from
charities and burning down puppy farms
you've got another hour and a half with
this guy folks NOLA go below helmet
tries to offer herself to all but that
will require him having an emotion so he
turns her down taking it to trial and
killings a hard thing to do well it's
not like acting
so I guess her trying to kill him
softens him up apparently as he decides
not to finish the girl off but she soon
turns out to be a nuisance as she draws
all over his boat and continues to
pester him free to you I told Helen you
wouldn't be so ugly to cut your hair
that you talk all the time come on y'all
once again are here or everybody tired
of hating the Nazis so much why don't
you try to make character of this film
there's plenty of jerk to go around
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
literally she can't swim
she's in the place called water world
and she can't swim it's nice I like
being an Antarctic and not knowing how
to put on a coat I mean oh something's
going on saying so Kozma swings around
and takes them both on but before they
could I don't know develop character two
of the smokers arrived and tried to
destroy it
by the way that's Jack Black piloting
the plane there you'll remember him from
such future disappointments as golfers
travels
so the plane is stuck swinging around
the boat as the pilot tries to cut the
wire
upsetted our actions costner does the
ballsiest thing he can think of she
gives her a haircut I'm not even joking
but that's really what he does don't
never touch anything on my boat again
next time it'll be a perm with blond
highlights he does the same thing to the
girl turning her into hailey Joe Osmond
just as they come across another drifter
I thought you all stop for each other
Jesus lady to pass a kidney stone online
they need up with the drifter who I
swear to God is played by a perverted
Robin Williams that she'll believe harm
gone there know what you want for the
women not for sale
a big pair or would you consider selling
something you know women I want to buy
your women the little girl your doctors
sell them don't shut up
what if I've been it with the one I like
too good to talk to me so just a
backtrack everybody the most expensive
film at the time included incest child
murder and now pedophilia how is it this
film can connect with a mainstream
audience again but just as the drifter
is about to rock her beau Costner
changes his mind and saves her
I think it's safe to say this isn't
worth any amount of oh no he painted his
back red that's just annoying nanu Egon
such a sweet sorrow
so costner goes to try and get some fat
by using himself as bait he kills a sand
worm in the water as a bit of a paradox
as he finally manages to feed everybody
I see tall people
so Cass nerd either sporadically decides
he does like the kid now and it's going
to show her how to swim
with the water tell your arms and legs
have me gone down hold your breath so we
get a good minute and a half just the
two of them swimming which after you
introduce the idea of pedophilia in this
world is starting to look a little
suspicious I'm not saying I'm just
saying that once you drop that bomb you
drop that fucking bomb okay so they come
across another trap set by the smokers
they turn around and try to hightail it
but hopper gets a good shot and then
wounds Costner pretty hard
it's hurt three but Costner heals pretty
fast in fact I dare say it doesn't
affect him at all as Helen demands that
Costner takes her to see tribal get in
she'll be fine just ignore the fact that
you just escaped the terrorists they're
most likely tracking you right now and
literally you're not moving let's just
put the idiot clock up there to count
down what a dumb idea this was so he
trades are underwater in this safety
bubble only to show her that dry land is
all washed up of course you could make
the argument that the air pressure would
kill her and if not she probably run out
of oxygen eventually but like I said
let's keep it one level at a time and
speaking of which the idiot clock is
almost up oh whoa the smokers got her
well if I didn't know any better I'd say
you do work they jump in the water and
Costner briefs oxygen into her mouth
leaving the smokers to destroy the boat
and taking a long way to try to figure
out the map on her back
my boat you maniacs
you blew it up damn you damn you Aldo so
as they sit there stranded Helen asks
Costner a question when I offered myself
to you
why didn't you take me
because you didn't really want me well
it's good to know he's an ethical savage
trying to murder children sell women and
drowning little girls is fine but when a
lady says nope he knows it means no so
while participating in post boat burning
stepdaughter kidnapping and nevertheless
sex which let's be honest is the best
sex the mother of all friggin
coincidences takes place yeah I guess he
got that whole controlling the balloon
so he can pick up people thing figure it
out but it turns out other people
survived as they band together and tried
to figure out what to do there's land
it's right under our keel and always
been there I know that now so this is
ridiculous oh you think he was talking
about the plan I think you'll talk about
Costner's Act I don't care about dry
land this is ridiculous
so Kazmir decides to go after Enola
along finding the smoker ship and being
lucky enough to find a series of holes
that just happen to lead right up the
boat lucky lucky Oh Godfrey coming to
rescue you he's not a freak and he can
take you anytime
he's killed dozens of people it doesn't
have any mercy or anything even kills
little girls have any so death can't
find him doesn't have a home or people
to care for not afraid of anything
many least of all you know it's pretty
bad when a little girl has to be your
spokesperson in a movie it doesn't make
the hero look especially tough I mean
can you imagine if samuel l.jackson from
pulp fiction had a kid as a spokesperson
he can block out the light of a thousand
suns his teeth can take out even the
biggest of caverna beggars and his
casted views of the end where it makes
my mommy so angry that he's well where
they are oh sorry did I break your
concentration he's fast and strong with
the big wind
he can hear 100 miles and see a hundred
miles underwater behind the shadow of
the noon Sun captain Cox nerd is so
matey that they say even blood the beer
joke had no feet up
so hopper hypes up the crew by showing
them that he has the map to dryland this
encourages the crew the keep on rolling
which let's be honest looks unbelievably
silly but Costner comes in after the
crowd has left to get his friend back
you guys are in so much trouble
thank you can I see it again got this
half I guess he a cycle of that I
thought you were stupid Glen but I
underestimated you
you are a total freaking retard I want
the girl that's all Hey
just now the curiosity um why aren't
they shooting yeah isn't this just
giving him time to whip out a flare
light it up drop it down a pipe and
block the entire ship yes it is
now to be fair this does lead to a very
funny scene where the lung guy who lives
a very tortured life looking after the
oil sees the flare drop oh thank god
okay you've gotta admit that's really
funny something all right show me the
scene again thank you
so hopper gets the girl to the plane as
we finally get the showdown between
Costner and Goldilocks here you should
stay on the water
well isn't that a really build up to an
unbelievable letdown so we see that
Hopper is getting away with D NOLA on
the plane
what's Costner to do
god bless you stuff so costner get seen
Ola to the balloon but again hopper
being the world's greatest shot knocks
wrong key and some henchmen tried to get
to her as Costner thinks up a plan which
leads to and let's be honest here one of
the stupidest rescue scenes ever
what the flying fuck bucket this whole
movie is bent on showing us all the
technical aspects and exactly how it
works and yet the last big action scene
comes down to a wily coyote scenarios oh
and I just love how they happened to
have the exact amount of bungee cord
from the balloon to the water to pull
this stunt off what a quality douche man
what a bloody two
so Gregor finally figures out the
language on her back and figures out the
way to dry land and of course when Genoa
they eventually come across it
all right I want to end this review so
insert lost Blue Lagoon Swiss Family
Robinson Jurassic Park and/or Gilligan's
Island joke here get creative so Costner
of course says he doesn't belong in this
world and decides to go back to the sea
I guess he prefers drinking his own piss
he says goodbye to the girl who gives
the most non-caring kiss ever given to a
woman and sets out to let people down
again in the postman who okay
that's Waterworld one of the biggest
bombs of all time but isn't one of the
worst movies of all time
well let's look at the bad stuff Costner
sabore there's a ton of little Platt
holes that do start to add up and as far
as the expensive movie at the time goes
yeah I probably expect a lot more to but
for what it is just a basic shoot-'em-up
action film it's not that bad
the sets are a lot of fun you really get
an atmosphere for this world Dennis
Hopper is enjoyably over the top and to
be honest I kind of like stuff watching
the tentacles of this world is really
enjoyable
I like seeing how everything works and
functions as it makes the world seem a
lot more practical and real but does
that make it a good movie no but I don't
see how that makes it an awful one
either maybe in a way that's it's worse
cry one of the most expensive movies of
all time and it's just okay it's not
spectacular Lee bad or spectacularly
good it's just okay for many movie goers
simply being an okay movie is the
biggest letdown but for me this simply
means it's okay take what you will from
that and decide on hero I'm the
Nostalgia Critic I remember it so you
don't have to one more time
you
ah